[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF BOLIBA: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeff Boliba.
I'm the Vice President of
Global Resorts at Burton.
And I've had the
pleasure of knowing
Kelly Clark for 18 years.
She is absolutely incredible.
Whether it's helping us out
with a resort photo shoot
or helping us introduce
really young kids
to snowboarding and
physical education
in elementary schools, Kelly
has always made the time.
No matter what community
she's living in,
she always wants to give back.
If you take a look
at her career,
it's absolutely incredible,
spanning 18 years,
five Olympics, three Olympic
medals, eight US Open medals,
and 14 X Games medals.
Now if you stack her against
the top female athletes,
if you look right there, that
47% win rate is outstanding.
So 47% of the time she entered a
snowboard competition, she won.
So impressive.
If you stack it against
the top male athletes,
once again, you'll see how
impressive that win rate is.
So I'm very honored and excited
to introduce Kelly Clark to you
today.
But before I do
that, I want to share
one of her winning moments.
SPEAKER: The
winningest the US Open
rider in the history
of this event,
coming out of West
Dover, Vermont,
riding for Burton Snowboards,
this is Kelly Clark.
What a show she put on today.
And it was typical Kelly Clark.
She drops in for her first run,
puts down a score of 86.88,
the highest of the day.
The other rider, she's not
too far ahead of [INAUDIBLE]..
What does she do
on her second run?
She ups it three points, 89.33.
And I would not be surprised
right now if Kelly put down
a run in the 90s, even
though she doesn't need
it, even though this
her victory lap,
Kelly Clark might want to
just put an exclamation
point on this, so when you
look at the standings tomorrow,
you know, oh, yeah, Kelly blew
the rest of the field away,
and she's doing so right now.
Look at how high she's
landing on that transition.
Tail right below the
lip, pumping the wall,
keeping a hard edge
to the flat bottom,
and going absolutely massive.
Kelly Clark is just putting
on a clinic right now.
That was unbelievable.
JEFF BOLIBA: Wow.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Kelly Clark.
[APPLAUSE]
KELLY CLARK: Thanks, Jeff.
Thanks for the
introduction, Jeff.
Thanks everybody for coming
and hanging out with us today.
It's a huge honor
for me to be here.
.
I'm excited to get to share some
of my life, some of my process.
Sports have such a good
way of just illustrating
kind of life's principles.
I've been with Burton Snowboards
for the last 20 years.
This marks my 20th
year with the brand,
which is a pretty
incredible relationship I've
had with them.
I've had a abnormally
long snowboard career.
I'm technically very old to
be a pro snowboarder at 35.
So it's been really fun, though.
I've really learned
everything that I've
learned to kind of
develop into the person
that I am through snowboarding.
They have kind of a
rubber meets the road type
of ability to show you
what you're capable of,
and show you what you
built. I always say
I trained 30 seconds--
I trained four years for
a 30 second half pipe run.
So there's a lot that goes
into the behind the scenes
that people don't see.
Any snowboarders in here?
Any skiers in here?
OK.
You guys can stay.
We still like you.
[LAUGHING]
I was up in Tahoe last week.
And there's a lot
better snow than there
has been in the last few years.
So it should be a
really fun winter.
I grew up in Vermont.
I live in Sacramento
currently, and I started
snowboarding when I was seven.
It was the first year
it was even allowed
at my home resort, 1990.
I always say that I
started snowboarding
before it was cool.
There was no such thing
as the Winter X Games.
And it was long before it
ever became an Olympic sport.
And honestly, I never
wanted to compete.
It was really--
I actually was a ski racer.
And I skipped enough
ski racing practice
to have my parents
stop paying for that,
just so I could
snowboard all the time.
And I never wanted to compete,
because the kind of ski racing
vibe was really cutthroat
and competitive.
And as a young kid, it
just didn't appeal to me.
And I had the opportunity
to go to a high school,
where it was essentially
a private school where
I could go to school half
day and snowboard half day,
and that sounded like a
pretty good gig to me.
And I just knew I wanted to
spend more days on the hill.
And to be able to go to this
school, I had to compete.
So I thought, OK, I'll
get in the competition.
That was when I
was 14 years old.
And I actually just kind
of fell in love with it.
I was halfway decent
at it, which was great.
And I really enjoyed it.
And then I remember,
you don't often
think you make big decisions
when you're 14 years old.
It was 1998, and it
was the first year
that snowboarding
became an Olympic sport.
And I remember I had
recorded it on a VHS tape.
Anybody?
VHS tapes.
I probably like,
recorded over an episode
of "Friends" or something.
But I had recorded the
Olympics, snowboarding's debut.
And I remember everything
about that day.
I remember where I was.
I remember what I was wearing.
I remember what the
weather was like.
And I saw snowboarding
become an Olympic sport,
and I knew right then and there
that this was a dream, that I
wanted to give my life to.
And four years later, I found
myself in my first Olympics
in 2002.
I then followed it up
with Italy and Torino.
Vancouver, Sochi, Russia,
and then my last Olympics
was in Korea.
So over 16 years,
I've had the privilege
representing my country
five different times.
And I've won, lost, draw.
All that.
I've had a wide range
of Olympic experiences.
And it's been fun to
kind of pull on those
and see the personal
growth in my life.
Through snowboarding,
I've learned
to be successful, so to speak.
I've learned a great
deal about failure.
But more so than anything, I've
learned to enjoy what I do.
And that's what I want
to talk about today.
How do we not only
be successful,
but how do you actually
thrive in the environment
that you're in?
And, you know, I live in
a performance culture.
Every weekend in the
winter, I go out there
and see what I built, and
see if I have what it takes.
But you don't have
to be an Olympian
to find yourselves living
in a performance culture.
We only have to
pick up our phones
to have a glance at social media
and start comparing ourselves
to one another.
It's where we find ourselves
living a lot of the time,
is in this performance world.
But the good news is
is just because we
live in this culture, it
doesn't mean that culture
gets to live with inside of us.
So there's a few
things that I want
to touch on today
that have really
helped me learn to thrive
in that environment
and that performance world.
And I'm just going
to hit on those.
And I'm going to tell a few
stories to kind of illustrate
that.
Does that sound good?
So we talk about
performance culture,
but what does that
actually mean?
In the performance world, it
says, I wonder if I'm enough.
I will sacrifice respect
and honor to get ahead.
I will work for everything.
And I will compete to
earn what I deserve.
And this is the big thing.
External success is
the only thing that
matters in a performance world.
So those are the things, that's
a place we find ourselves in.
It seems pretty extreme when
I list it out like that.
But those are the things--
that's the race we find
ourselves in a lot of the time.
And I'm just going to touch on
thriving here for a minute too.
How many of you guys
have succulents at home?
Anybody?
Proud succulent owner?
Would you say they're
thriving, or RIP succulents?
Maybe RIP succulents, huh?
That happens.
You know, you can be
successful and not be thriving,
but it's hard to be thriving
and not feel successful.
And it only takes us
looking at our house plants
to see if something's thriving.
And usually when
something's thriving,
it means that it's growing.
And that's honestly
what it means to thrive.
If something's growing, we say,
oh, we put that plant right
where it needed to be.
We gave it the right
amount of water.
It's in the right environment.
And when it grows,
that's what we say.
Hey, my plants are thriving.
I don't know how many green
thumbs we have in here.
But I know you
often think you're
thriving when you're winning.
You think you're thriving
when you're successful.
But as I'll kind
of dive into this,
success just looks like growth.
And that's what we need
to be doing in our lives.
And that's what we need to
be putting in the win column.
So the few things that
I want to bring up
that I've really found in
my career that have helped
me be successful and
thrive and enjoy what I do,
honestly, it all starts
with our identity.
It's so easy to get
a sense of self-worth
and a sense of significance
wrapped up in our performance.
In sports, we see it the most.
We see that the
roughest transition
is when people-- when
athletes retire, because they
get so much of their self-worth
in their performance.
And it's a natural thing to do.
That's how we
identify each other.
When we meet people, we
say, oh, who are you,
and what do you do?
It's very easy to find yourself
operating in that place.
But I'd like to
propose that success
isn't what we're looking for.
I think we're looking for a
deep sense of significance.
And I think we try to
fill that with success
and with performance.
I know I've done that
a ton in my career.
When your self-worth is
tied to your performance,
we can't take risks.
Think about it.
If I'm in a snowboard
contest, and--
I'll actually use an
example from Russia.
Heading into the 2014 Olympics,
I was a heavy gold medal
favorite.
I was supposed to perform well.
I was probably, if I looked back
at my career, that was probably
kind of the prime time
of my snowboard career.
And I was 30 years old and
it was my fourth Olympics.
I had kind of all the
bugs out of my system.
I was pretty comfortable,
knowing what I
wanted to accomplish that time.
And when we showed up for
the event, it was 55 degrees.
And if anybody knows what snow
does when it's 55 degrees,
it becomes very challenging.
And I took my first
run at 1:00 PM,
and three rounds of competition
happened before my final run,
which was around 9:00 PM.
And if you can imagine
in those temps,
the pipe deteriorated
in epic fashion.
When I showed up for
finals, I remember
I took five runs in
practice for finals,
and I moved my 1080
three different times.
And I couldn't get it to work.
I fell five runs in a row
in my practice for finals.
And now, that
doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to
fall in the contest.
But especially, at
the Olympics, like
you want your
practice to go well.
It's going to kind of set
the tone for your performance
that evening.
I remember I went down, and I
saw a sea of Team USA people
kind of staring at me, knowing
that the train had completely
fallen off the tracks.
And I saw my sports
psychologist,
and I looked at her, and I
said, hey, you know what?
I actually need to go
and have a good cry.
And then I think I'm
going to be ready.
I think if your significance
and your personal view
is tied to your
performance, you really
can't take those risks
that you need to,
because everything in life is
an opportunity or a threat.
And I needed to look at that
moment as an opportunity.
And in a performance
world, we're
at our worst when we're afraid.
If you ever seen somebody--
I heard a story of someone
drowning, you know.
When somebody goes to
save them, they actually
try to drown the person
that's trying to save them.
We are at our worst
when we are afraid.
And I was looking at these
next two runs in the Olympics.
I had waited four years.
I had spent an entire
lifetime since I
was 14 investing in this dream.
And it's going as bad
as it possibly can go.
After my ugly cry,
I went to the top.
And I said, OK, this
is an opportunity
to overcome a bad situation.
And you know what happened?
My next run, I went, and I
landed my 10 for the first time
that night, but took
off early on my seven.
And I hit the deck.
And I like to call it like,
a reverse taco, if you
can imagine that.
I bounced to the
flat, reverse taco,
and I fell in epic fashion.
And I was probably more
prepared for a first run
fall than a poor practice.
I knew, even though, I'd
fallen six runs in a row,
I still had an opportunity.
If I was so caught up in
the expectation of being
the gold medal favorite,
if I was so caught up
in maintaining my reputation
and what people thought,
and what I even
demanded of myself,
I would not be in an
opportunity position.
I would be in a threat.
And in a performance world,
we need to be at our best.
I went back to the top,
and I saw my coach.
And we had been through this
scenario a lot of times.
Those first run
falls, it happens.
This last week,
I was counting up
a bunch of my competition bibs.
And I have over 190.
And so those first run falls,
it's happened a few times.
And I went back up.
And to be quite honest,
it was the hardest thing
that I ever did.
But I told my coach,
hey, what an opportunity.
Six runs, I've
fallen consecutively.
I was the last person to
go over the entire event,
because I'd qualified
first for finals,
and we run in reverse order.
And I dropped in
and I landed a run.
And it was good enough to
put me on the Olympic podium.
And I'd fallen in six runs in
a row, only to land my seventh,
when it mattered most.
And I was so proud
of my performance.
It wasn't necessarily
my best snowboarding.
I've snowboarded a
lot better than that.
But to overcome that
personally in that situation,
I was really able to--
those situations, they reveal
where your identity is.
When you look to what you're
responding to around you,
and how you're going to
react in those situations,
we need to be our best.
And that sort of
outlook, looking
at things as an opportunity,
is really a big way to do that.
How you guys doing?
You're awfully quiet.
Everybody good?
So the next thing
I want to touch on
is we need to have a
healthy idea of success.
If you want to thrive in
a performance culture,
that's something that you're
going to have to work out.
What does success
look like to you?
You know, honestly, that's what
I set out to do with my book.
I wanted to help people define
success in a healthy way.
As you can gather,
my idea of success
necessarily isn't
confined to just winning.
If I were to say what my
personal definition of it
is, I want to be able to look
back at my journey and say,
I was really faithful
with the opportunities
that were in front of me,
and I didn't let one go by.
And I also ask myself
if I was growing.
If those two things are
happening in my life,
if I made the most
of my opportunities,
and I had some
measure of growth,
honestly, that's more successful
than you could ever hope to be.
And the last thing
of my little mini
list here that I want
to set you guys up
with is, after 20
years of snowboarding,
I've come to the conclusion
that if your dream only includes
you, it's too small of a dream.
I found that we're
really thriving in life
when other people are involved.
You know, whatever
culture you live in,
whatever dream you're building,
if you're the only one in it,
it's just too small of a dream.
If you build your
yourself, your influence
will go away when you're
no longer performing.
You limit yourself if
you only build yourself.
We have to figure out how to
build things that will outlast
our ability to perform.
So a few of the just kind of
fundamental building blocks.
We've got to work out
that identity piece.
We have to develop a
healthy idea of success.
And we have to find
value in building others.
But the most important
thing that I've
learned throughout my career
has really helped me thrive.
I've learned to look at
the things that no one sees
and treat them as more
valuable than the things
that everyone sees.
If it sounds strange and
unfamiliar, it's because it is.
It's not natural.
It's not our go-to.
But the world inside of me
and the personal victories
and the wins that aren't on TV,
that nobody beyond my friends
and family will ever
see, those are the things
that I value much more
than any placement,
than any medal that I can win.
The world inside
of you has to be
more important than
the world around you.
If you ever find yourself--
if you ever feel like
life's happening to you,
it's a pretty good
indication that you're not
living from a value set
and making decisions.
You're not living intentionally.
You're living reactionary.
And we really have to
work on this inner world,
this idea of success,
this identity stuff.
Our big picture and
building others.
And we have to learn to
treat the things that nobody
sees as more important than
the ones that are on display?
So there is a--
how many of you guys watched
the Olympics this last year?
Anybody catch the
woman's half pipe?
I was there.
You know, this is
the ultimate story
of valuing things that no
one sees more than what
the NBC cameras will show you.
I set out to do the
impossible last year.
No woman from the US had ever
made five winter Olympic teams
in any sport.
And, you know, I've been the
veteran now for, I don't know,
10 years in snow boarding.
The women that I compete
with are quite literally
half my age.
If I remember, I believe
it was two summers ago,
I was on the podium
with two women.
And if you added up their ages,
it literally equaled mine.
And I'm 35.
It's like, I'm not old.
I didn't think I was
old, until I look around,
and they say the TV shows that
I like aren't funny because they
have live studio audiences.
It's interesting.
It happens quick.
But I knew this Olympics
would be my last rodeo.
It would be the last time I
got the chance to do this.
And in January, I found myself
named to the Olympic team.
And it was in Mammoth
Mountain California,
which was my home
resort for a long time.
And it was just a sweet win at
that final Olympic qualifier.
Now they named the
Olympic qualifier--
they named the Olympic
team, the last qualifiers,
only two weeks before
opening ceremony starts.
So it's not this,
you know you're
on the team for a long time.
There's literally two weeks.
And I think the night that
you get named to the team,
the team manager is calling
you to book your plane ticket,
because they need to pay for it.
And there's a small
contest that falls in
between when they name the team
and when we go to the Olympics.
And it's called the X Games.
And a lot of people will--
you can look at it two ways.
You can look at it as an
opportunity or a threat.
You could say, hey, this
is a great opportunity
to go to this big event and get
ready for the biggest event.
Or I could play it
safe and say, you know,
I don't want to get hurt.
I should probably protect
myself and play it safe.
Which is something I've
never been good at it.
And best way to get
ready for a big contest
is going to a big contest.
And so I go to
this event, and I'm
trying to get my snowboarding
to where it needs to be.
And my first run's pretty good.
I think I'm sitting in
second or third place.
And I'm pushing myself,
trying to get my snowboarding
to where it needs to be.
And in my second run, I
go down extremely hard.
I hit the deck again
and bounced to the flat.
And I actually was pretty
OK up until that point.
But when I hit the flat, my
left knee was so crumpled--
I was so crumpled.
My left knee hit
my left shoulder.
And I heard a loud
pop in my left knee.
And I remember sitting there
with the Mega Mo Follow Cam Ski
Guy in my face with a camera,
not being able to breathe,
because I had knocked the wind
down myself, thinking, I'm
pretty sure I just blew my ACL.
And I'm thinking, I just
made the Olympic team.
And I don't think I'm ever
even going to get to go.
So I pick myself up.
I go down to the
bottom of the pipe.
And the US team, we have all
of our doctors and surgeons
on hand.
And I say, hey, I'm
pretty sure I heard a pop,
and I'm pretty sure I just
heard my ACL go in my knee.
And I can already feel
there's fluid in the top
of my calf above my
boots filling with fluid,
and my joints beginning
to stiffen up.
And so we go there,
and X Games has
their team of
orthopedic surgeons,
and my own team of
orthopedic surgeons.
And there's a manual
test you can do-- you
guys are familiar-- to kind of
see if you have an endpoint.
So they're doing all
the manual tests.
Multiple high level orthopedic
guys are all testing my knee,
and they think I
have an endpoint.
We think you have an ACL.
But we're going to have
to wait till Monday.
And we'll get the MRI, and we'll
figure out what's going on.
Monday comes around.
And the radiologist is looking
at the films after my MRI.
And they can kind of--
they know how to read the
films, and they can kind of
get an idea of what's
going on in there.
So I was asking the
guy, I was like, hey,
do you see my
ligaments in there?
You know, how's it look?
And he's like, you know, I don't
know much about your ligaments,
but I do see the tibial plateau
fracture that's clear as day.
And I thought, I'm sorry, what?
He's like, yeah, the
fracture in your tibia.
That's really clear to see.
I don't know if you
have ligaments or not.
But definitely broke your leg.
And I didn't see that coming.
I talked to my
surgeon that night,
and I said, hey,
what's going on?
And he said, you have an ACL.
You have a severe bone
bruise, and you've
cracked your tibial plateau.
The good news is is it's
in an area where it's not
extremely weight bearing.
But you definitely
have a fracture.
What does this mean?
You know, what are
we looking at now?
We've got maybe week and a
half until we fly to Korea.
So we get my coach on the phone,
and we look at everything.
And they say, hey,
you know, we think
we can get you through this.
And he said, here's the plan.
We brace you up with this
giant mechanical leg.
We medially load your knee to
create a little bit of space
in your joint, and we load
you up on WADA and USADA
approved anti-inflammatories.
And you have to agree
not to practice up
until semi-qualifiers
for the Olympic games.
And I said, hey, I
think we can do that.
But I had to ask my coach.
I said, hey, if you
want to send somebody
who perhaps doesn't
have a broken leg,
I would give up my spot.
I understand.
I understand that.
He said, no, I would
always bet on you.
You know?
And so I have the most
incredible support team.
And I put full faith
and full trust in them.
And I flew to my fifth Olympics
with a fractured tibia.
I remember I was
late for my plane,
actually, in San
Francisco, and I
was trying to get to
the plane quickly,
and I couldn't even run walk.
It was excruciating.
And I'm thinking,
what am I doing?
I got to Korea.
We gradually got me in the gym.
I didn't practice
for the entire event.
I think I took three runs in
the half pipe before qualifiers.
Qualifiers came around,
and I just barely
snuck in there, because I mean,
every half pipe's so different.
And honestly, learning to
ride with a mechanical leg.
This sort of brace was very new
and very challenging for me.
And I snuck in there.
They took 12 people
in the finals,
and I qualified in 11th.
It was not my best
snowboarding, but I made it.
And I was honestly believing
the dream again at this point.
I was thinking, gosh,
I've overcome so much.
I totally want that
fairy tale ending.
I want that medal.
I want one more kind of
just that fairy tale ending.
I wanted to finish well.
And I can honestly
say the day of finals,
anti-inflammatory
pills, adrenaline,
whatever it was, I
can honestly say,
my injury did not
affect my performance.
That day, I rode lights out, as
the kids say, out of my mind.
And I rode so well.
I put down three runs that
were perfect, in my mind.
I could have dealt with less
tears and more practice.
But my performance that
day, it was as good
as it could have been.
I put down some of my best
runs at my fifth Olympic games.
And I came so far,
overcame so much.
And I was waiting for my
final score to pop up.
And I didn't see the letter, or
the number one, two, or three,
but I saw the
number four pop up.
And I would remain in fourth.
Keeping my Olympic streak alive,
to never worse than fourth,
which is pretty good.
But fourth, you only get
your participation medal
from the Olympics,
which is probably
controversial in itself,
participation medals.
But I didn't get on the podium.
And I remember standing
there, and I had
a microphone put in my face.
And in front of millions
and millions of people,
I was asked for a reason
why this didn't work out.
What happened, Kelly?
What went wrong?
And I had every opportunity
to find a reason why.
I actually had a
good reason why.
PS, I broke my
leg two weeks ago.
But you know what happened?
The world inside of me
popped to the surface.
And I was able to respect the
people I was competing with.
I was able to respect the
judging and the formats.
I was able to keep my
integrity and keep my honor.
And the world
inside of me proved
to be much bigger than the world
that I was in at that time.
People always ask me what one
of my Olympic medals, which
I brought with me today--
I'll let you guys all
check them out at the end.
You know, which one
of your Olympic medals
means the most to you?
And I've really found that
they're very prestigious,
but it's what they represent
that gives them value.
And you value things based
off of what they cost you.
You know, some of
these medals are
more expensive than perhaps
the one when I was 18.
You know?
I won Olympic gold in Salt Lake
City when I was 18 years old.
And it's easy being a rookie.
No expectation.
No pressure.
Russia, I would say, is
probably my favorite medal,
because I know what it cost me.
It was so expensive.
It took everything that I had.
You know, my idea of
a fairy tale ending
was one more shot at
that Olympic podium.
But I think standing
upright in the face of loss,
in the face of
disappointment, was perhaps
the most valuable end
that I ever could've had.
And that moment was
much more costly.
Keeping your integrity
cost a lot sometimes.
You don't find it in very
fun situations, often.
But I'm beginning to
see that, perhaps, I
should view that experience
differently because
of the success and the
win that actually happened
on the inside of me
that people wouldn't say
was necessarily successful.
No one knew what I
overcame that day.
At the end of the
event, I went home,
and I had hundreds of text
messages and voice mails
and emails.
And I kind of just bleary
eyed stared at my phone.
And there was one
message that popped up
that caught my
attention, and I think,
speaks to the value of what
actually happened that day.
It's from my longtime
manager, who I've been
with since I was 15 years old.
And he had watched the
event on TV with his son.
And he wrote me this email
I'm going to read to you.
He said, "Congratulations
on an amazing finals.
If you've taught
me one thing, it's
that we're fools to allow
the judgment of others
to influence our own
appreciation of performance.
This seems especially
true today.
Having seen each of your Olympic
runs over your long career,
I can say this with
some of your best work.
You started strong, yet
strategically contained,
pushed it further in the
second, and under the greatest
pressure, crushed
it in the third.
It reminds me of Torino,
where you did more
for women's snowboarding
than most gold medal
performances combined.
You'll enjoy listening to
Todd Richards' commentary
about what he thought
about your run.
I saw your interview after
the event with Tina Dixon.
I could see and feel your
frustration and disappointment,
but your maturity and
perspective prevailed,
and you showed
class and composure
that few athletes could muster.
Benny--" who's his son--
"who is now 14 was watching
with me, and he asked me, Dad,
how can she be so calm
and nice after that?
I smiled when he asked me that.
Through five Olympics,
Kelly, you've
managed to find so many ways in
addition to winning and medals
to inspire people to be better
than they could have previously
imagined.
And as much as I know
you wanted to win,
and I wanted you to
win as a parent would,
it's much more
precious an opportunity
to discover a moment
of such magnitude,
and as an athlete of
such profound talent
and historical
significance to demonstrate
the values you embody.
There will be many medals
awarded over these Olympics,
but I know Benny
wouldn't have asked me
that question had you not
thrown down the runs you did,
been dealt the
scores you received,
and handled it the way you did.
And in terms of
inspiration, it's
moments like that can make a
huge difference in a kid's life
and in the world.
I'm so proud of you, Kelly.
What you've done, who you are,
and how you've lived your life.
And I've been privileged
to be part of it.
And the effect
you have on people
transcends results, medals,
and transcends snowboarding.
I can't wait to see
how you inspire people
outside of the half pipe,
whenever that may be.
And I promise you
that I'll support you
in those efforts however I
can for as long as I can."
So we measure success based
off of what color medal we get,
and we don't always place a
value on things like this.
That was the message
that I needed
to hear when I went home
heartbroken that day,
realizing that there is so much
more than just performance.
It wasn't something
everyone saw,
but perhaps it's more valuable
than a million gold medals
could ever be.
We have to build things that
outlast our ability to perform.
My life is a testament
to going after a dream.
We're supposed to go after
all that's in our hearts
and hit all of our potential.
And it's not going to be
all rainbows and butterflies
all the time.
There's going to be
a lot of hard days.
But it should be enjoyable.
We think everything
should always be fun,
and people also hear
what I do for a living,
and they say, wow, that
must be really fun.
And I'm like, it is really fun.
And a lot of people, especially
professional athletes,
are like, why do you do it?
You're like, it's so fun.
Like, I'm sorry.
It's like, spoiler alert.
It's not always going to be fun.
But it should be enjoyable.
And if you can work
out how to not be
defined by what you do,
how to build others up,
how to define success
in a healthy way,
and how to value the
things that no one sees
more than the things
that are on display,
you will have a
successful career,
and there's going to
be a lot of growth,
you're going to be
thriving, and you're
going to be enjoying
what you do.
For me as a snowboarder,
I've had a very long career,
and I've had more success
than anyone could ever dream.
When I was 14, I've had
more success than I ever
began to dream about.
.
And I'm so thankful, and
it's been such a privilege.
And if it was about
accomplishing things,
if it was about winning
things, honestly,
I probably should have
stopped a long time ago.
You have to figure
out how to make
what you do more than that.
You have to figure out how to
develop something inside of you
that will sustain you no matter
what environment you go into.
Burnout doesn't come
from too much activity.
If anybody should be burned
out, it should be me.
I've done a million
snowboarding contests.
It really comes from
unmet expectations.
And so if you can spend time
developing that inner world,
you're going to be able
to go into any world
and hit your potential, and
be your best, and enjoy it.
And always remember that if
your dream only includes you,
it's just too small of a dream.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was curious,
at the beginning,
you said you were training
always for basically 30
seconds of a half pipe run.
And I'm curious how
you go about sort
of maintaining that
mindset of training when
the actual
performance, to me, it
seems like it's always so far
away, and such a blip in time.
KELLY CLARK: You
know, I think you
need to have an idea of what you
want to accomplish, regardless
of what's going on around you.
As I would approach
the Olympics,
I knew where my snowboarding
was going to need to be.
I think it's easy
to get caught up
in looking around to what my
fellow competitors were doing.
But if you can figure out what
it is you want to accomplish,
it's something that you
can work on regardless
of what's going on around you.
So it may look like what
we do is kind of like,
oh, my goodness, I just
tried this trick today.
I think it took me seven
years to first land a 1080.
So it's very much in the
scope of what you want to do.
And no matter what
you accomplish,
and especially in snowboarding,
like, you're never the best.
And there isn't a day that goes
by that I'm not challenged.
And I think that's
what kept me motivated,
as I enjoyed the challenge.
I enjoyed constantly
learning things.
And if I wasn't
learning new things,
I probably wouldn't have been in
the game for as long as I was.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thematic to everything you've
been able to discuss today,
did you ever have a
situation in your career
where you felt disconnected
from the things that brought
you and kept you in sport?
And if so, how did you
recognize a disconnect?
How did you identify
that was happening?
KELLY CLARK: I talk about
a lot of these concepts
and a lot of things
that have sustained me.
I mean, goodness, I like,
I wrote a book about it.
But you just never
arrive in life.
And there's so
many times where I
have to be willing to examine
my heart in situations
where I maybe didn't find my
inner world as well-developed
as I hoped, where maybe
jealousy popped up.
Maybe I wanted to be right.
Maybe I wanted to
have an excuse.
And the way that I
was able to really--
you have to be OK not
having it all together.
You never master it.
You have to be willing
to be a work in progress.
And when I found myself
maybe not operating
the way that I wanted to,
maybe I'm feeling really
threatened all of
the sudden, and I'm
like, wow, I thought I
had that figured out,
I thought I looked at
everything as an opportunity,
and I was killing it, I actually
really pulled on other people.
So being in community
and allowing people
into your process was
really, really healthy.
I think we have the idea,
especially in sports, where--
I mean, in all of
culture, we champion
self-made millionaires.
We say, when you're isolated,
when you came from nothing,
and now you're something.
I think you can be
successful, but it's not very
fulfilling doing it that way.
And letting people in--
behind every great athlete
is a team of great people.
There's no self-made
millionaires
in the athletic world.
And every time that
I failed, messed up,
felt like I had learned
this lesson long ago,
but I was relearning it
for the hundredth time,
it was my coaches,
and it was people
who believed in me
on the days that I
didn't believe in myself.
AUDIENCE: So first of
all, thanks for coming in.
Thanks for the talk.
My question is that,
now looking back
after having gone through
your career, if you were
to look back and talk to
the 14-year-old you who
was dreaming at the time,
and how things have changed
since then, what type of
advice and recommendation
would you give that you didn't
necessarily have back then?
KELLY CLARK: Honestly,
the most important thing
that I've ever learned
in my snowboarding career
is that identity thing.
I think not a lot of people get
to reach the top of something.
Most of the time life is a
journey and, all of a sudden,
I was 18 years old, and I won
the X Games, the Olympics,
and the US Open all
in the same season.
I'd accomplished everything
I ever wanted to do.
And I just had
equated that success
meant that I was fulfilled.
And at a really young age,
I had to figure that out.
I was like, wow, this
isn't what life's about.
My life is not
complete because I
accomplished a list of to-dos.
I had to develop a strong
sense of self outside of that.
And in the sports world,
you just see it so plainly.
There's such a
level of insecurity
in performance culture
that is just unsettling.
And so when I look at young
girls, that's the number one
thing that I say
to young athletes,
hey, you got to
figure this part out
before you can navigate
this really well.
Because it just makes it--
just doesn't make it fun.
There's so much more freedom
and so much more enjoyment
when you can sort that
identity piece out.
AUDIENCE: Where are your top
three mountains to snowboard?
KELLY CLARK: What did you say?
AUDIENCE: What's your top
three mountains to snowboard?
KELLY CLARK: I lived in
Mammoth, California forever,
and I love that resort.
They do a great job kind of
maintaining their terrain
parks, and then they get
like, 300 days of sun.
And when it's not sunny,
it's just nuking snow.
That's a great mountain.
Snowmass in Colorado is really
fun, if you like the groomers.
Really top notch groomers there.
And then my favorite
destination to go snowboarding
would be Japan.
Hokkaido, North Island Japan
is always my number one pick.
You ever get the
opportunity to go there,
I would highly recommend it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for coming, Kelly.
I'm curious just on
training routines,
training for an Olympics.
What did a typical
day look like?
And how did that change over
the course of your career?
KELLY CLARK: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Well, like I referenced
before, snowboarding really
wasn't a sport when I started.
And there's so much kind of
lifestyle and easy goingness
attached to it.
And I remember in 2010, I had
been to three Olympic games.
I had two Olympic medals.
And the US snowboard
team said, hey,
would you like to come
in for fitness testing?
Like, it just wasn't even
on our radar before then.
We're not like real
athletes, you know?
And so, I was like, yeah,
sure, that sounds good.
I could do some high jumps
for you, or whatever.
And I did it.
And I was like, hey,
what do my results mean?
And my trainer, to
this day, I still
bring this up every once
in a while, she says, wow,
you are really mentally--
you must be really
mentally strong.
And I was like, wait,
this is a fitness test.
Like, that's like
telling someone
have a nice personality,
or like, you're
beautiful on the
inside, you know?
And I'm like, seriously?
And she's like, yeah, like
it's pretty incredible what
you've been able to accomplish.
And I'm like, what?
And hence, all this like,
inner personal, inner world
development.
You know?
But I could have either
been really offended,
or looked at it
as an opportunity.
And I said, you know what?
This is an untapped resource.
So in 2010, I said,
hey, let's figure out
what it looks like to
train a snowboarder.
We don't even know.
There's no data.
We know how to train baseball
players and football players.
But we don't know, what does
it look like for ideal body
comps and different things?
So I said, I give
you four years.
And in those four years,
when I was mentioning
kind of my peak of
my career, I went up
to winning 86% of the
contests I entered.
And my consistency
and my durability
went through the roof.
And I was the only one on the
US team in a four year span
who didn't require a surgery.
And I was older than everybody.
And I was just like,
oh, my goodness,
this is an incredible resource.
And so, that was a big part of
the second part of my career.
And heading into
this last Olympics,
I think I was logging 22 to
24 hours of dry land training
a week.
And it's a lot of--
light and lean is what
we would train for.
We'd have two days
of cardio, and we'd
have two days of strength
training, three days of core.
And they would kind of
overlap over a six-day span
with one day off.
So light and lean, a
lot of stability stuff,
a lot of body weight stuff.
I can get more into
detail after it,
but it's kind of a
work in progress.
And we would profile
my body comps
when I would
perform really well,
and we'd start to
discover, OK, so
I'm performing my best when
my body looks like this.
OK.
That's our target.
Like, we were
starting from scratch.
So.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Thanks for everything
you've done for the sport.
My question is, being
a woman snowboarder,
was there a point where you
realized that you were not only
a champion for the
snowboarding sport as a whole,
but for women boarders, and
then becoming a household name
as a woman athlete?
KELLY CLARK: Yeah, you know,
in snowboarding, there's
not the different sized
ball that we play with.
We're on the same kind
of venue as the guys.
And when I was growing
up, I was one girl kind
of in a pack of guys.
And I got on the US team.
And then I found kind of a
crew of girls to ride with.
And there was people who went
before me that really inspired
me and that I looked up to.
I remember waiting in line
to get people's autographs
at the US Open, and then I found
myself a little kids waiting
in line to get autographs at
the US Open when I was 18.
And I thought, gosh,
I am in a position
to be able to inspire people.
And that's kind of
how I looked at it.
I thought, I have
a responsibility
and an opportunity to impact
people in a positive way.
And I just looked at
it as a privilege.
And I tried to do my best,
knowing that I really
had a lot of influence.
And, you know, there
is not a ton of--
I think at Burton,
we have a woman CEO,
and she's been an advocate
for women and for everything
from equal prize money
to women in leadership
at the company for
a very long time.
And so, we didn't see it
as a huge kind of contrast
between the men and
women, because I
think I was so close to
it, and our leadership
was always empowering women.
It just kind of seemed
natural and normal.
When I kind of grew up a
bit and saw other sports,
I realized how unique
snowboarding actually was.
So I just tried to make
sure that I was always,
I guess, the same person too.
I think anytime you're
in a place of influence
you, want to be the same
person that you are when you're
winning or losing, at
the top of the hill,
at the bottom of the hill, when
you're home with your friends,
and when you're
with your family.
And so I strive to live
a life of consistency
and authenticity,
because I think
that's a huge attribute
in snowboarding
that we have a huge value for.
And I think it's
been a cool journey
to see the sport
grow, especially
with the young women.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious again, sort
of like a question about how
you deal with challenges.
And when you take
these massive slams,
you touched on
this a little bit,
but I was wondering if you
could go into a little bit more
detail about, what are
you really thinking about?
Like, how do you
actually get yourself
to come over that hurdle
right then and get yourself
up and go again?
KELLY CLARK: My
coach has a saying.
If it was easy, everybody
would be doing it.
And I heard that often
at the top of the pipe
when I was discouraged.
I kind of always had an idea
that nothing was impossible,
and I wouldn't let
my circumstances
decide things for me.
So even when I did
take those big crashes,
when I did take those big falls,
it was a mix of personal drive,
and then people believing in me
and speaking into me as well.
It was those coaches,
it was those friends,
it was the people--
being willing to ask for help
and not have it together all
the time, and being willing
to be challenged and fail,
to know that eventually you--
what is it?
Thomas Edison, he
just learned a bunch
of ways not to
make a light bulb.
Using all those
failures as like,
I learned one way not to do it.
I guess I should try again.
And you want to stay-- you
know, snowboarding, especially,
it's a high impact sport.
And you want to stay
within your ability level
when you take this.
And you want to be realistic.
And so in talking
to my coaches, do
you think this is a realistic
trick for me to work on?
And what kind of
steps am I going
to need to take to get there?
And not everything's instant.
And I think getting
strong enough
to take those risks, especially
as I got older in my career,
was really helpful as well.
So I knew if it didn't go well,
most likely, I would bounce.
Hopefully, I would bounce.
That was kind of my plan.
[LAUGHING]
Whether it's a good plan or not.
Was there a specific
trick or anything
else that made you
more nervous than usual
before a run or an event?
Typically, your most difficult
run or you most difficult trick
is the one you think about.
But it's kind of a catch-22,
because you really can only
focus on one thing at a time.
I remember we had a
sports psychologist come
by our team one time, and
he gave us two tennis balls.
One guy was supposed to throw
it up and down really quickly.
And the other one were supposed
to be thrown across the room.
And we were told to keep
track of how many times
each tennis ball was thrown.
After about 20 seconds he
said, what did you come up?
We were like, oh,
we all lost count.
And he said, m some point.
You can't focus on two
things at the same time.
And my 1080 was probably
my hardest trick.
But if I was thinking about
doing a 1080 on my third hit,
when I dropped in
for my first hit,
I guarantee you I would fall.
First hit on a straighter.
So, you know, you want to
anticipate those things.
But by the time you
get to those events,
by the time you get
to the Olympics,
like, you should
have figured out.
Those are muscle memory things.
They can be intimidating,
but it's not
going to be something
you're going to have
to think your way through.
Your body knows what
to do by that time.
And it was really
a battle to really
just stay on the task at
hand, or in the moment.
I remember I was hiking
up, one of my friends
that I snowboarded
with for a long time,
we had the same coach.
And she was talking through
her run with Ricky, my coach.
And it's going to
look like this.
I've got to do this.
And then I've got to
look here on this--
I've got to be careful to
keep my speed, and that.
And I'm like, listening
to her, like whoa.
That's a lot.
And Ricky looks at
me and he says, hey,
what you going to do kid?
I said, I'm going to
do a good drop in.
And they just looked at
me, and they just laughed.
They're like, seriously,
that's your plan?
I'm like, totally.
Everything else is--
I know how to do it.
I just have to make
sure I get in there.
And so it's a fine line
between being prepared,
and then, in the moment,
actually letting your body
know what it knows how to do.
JEFF BOLIBA: Thanks
so much, Kelly.
This was awesome.
KELLY CLARK: Well, thank
you very much, guys.
JEFF BOLIBA: Another
round of applause maybe?
[APPLAUSE]